the 17 year old who video recorded
george floyd's murder
is going to receive an honorary pulitzer
prize and i think this is a great
development so many people
felt powerless in the face of what was
happening to george floyd and others and
darnell fraser
who was only 17 at the time stood her
ground and recorded things she was
walking home with her nine-year-old
cousin
when she had the bravery to sit there
and record everything happening
of course many people wanted to
intervene but the fact of the matter is
if you intervene in a situation like
that you might be
charged with obstruction of justice or
assaulting a police officer
and it's not fair but those are the
rules
and what people can do is when they see
something that might be suspicious it's
not clear
simply record the police record the
activity that's what you can do as a
citizen to prevent these kinds of things
from happening in the future
it's sad but true but the conviction of
derek shovin probably wouldn't have
happened without the video evidence and
we should be encouraging citizen
journalists like this as much as we can